[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to a brand-new season at The
Omen eSports report but we've got a new
home and you look and well and you us it
is right Smaug myself and you will be
the hostess monthlies peek behind the
curtain each episode we'll be bringing
you the latest news the biggest guests
and some exclusive beats is that you
here's what we've got lined up to you
[Music]
[Music]
not see we've got no time to waste let's
get into the show
[Music]
[Music]
the latest news from around the world of
eSports and we will reckon we can give
you the top news ions in say just 60
seconds
sounds like there's only one person for
the job something that you'd choose mark
Wow no crush then well that leaves me
with one place to start with this 60
seconds and there's no better place than
the latest installment of the blast Pro
Series which took place in Madrid the
grand final saw ends take on the
powerhouse of Australia in a thrilling
final with ends ending the deign streak
of 31 wings on Nick to one-up before
sealing the title on train 1613 moving
over to League now with a midseason
Invitational which picked up on the
first of the month it's been a
heart-stopping rise for two of my
personal favorites you see the Stars g2
eSports and SS Team Liquid after some
tense moments of the group stages both
sides ultimately progressed to the
playoffs alongside SK Telecom t1 and
Invictus gaming whilst over on the dota
scene fans were treated to an incredible
tournament at the MDL Disneyland Paris
major Team Liquid storm through the
lower bracket only to have their hearts
broken as team secret secured a second
major of the season with a 3-1 win in
the grand final now to round things off
we've got some overwatch League news for
you and San Francisco shock the stage 2
champions a 4-2 victory over the
Vancouver Titans in the grand finals won
them $200,000 whilst local heroes lemon
spit fire obviously event in a super 8
position you know what that was actually
pretty good I was actually pretty good
I'll give it to you the first one 60
seconds you lie down after that you can
take a few moments but actually no part
because there's no time for that because
we got a few more news items that I
think deserve some attention as well now
first up there's been an exciting
announcement from the team over at
Ubisoft the Rainbow six siege major
taking place at a rally Convention
Center in August this will be featuring
the best players in the world and this
is an unmissable one for those frame
six fans out there tickets are on sale
now so make sure to go and snap some up
before they're gone another massive bit
of news that's dropped up for an event a
little bit closer to home is one that I
cannot wait for it is of course quake on
Europe and we're taking place in London
on July 26th and 27th running
simultaneously alongside quake on in
Dallas now if you want to get the first
hands-on experience of doom eternal
before your friends do your best bet is
to get yourself down there well I'm
gonna jump back in now mark because it's
time to talk business with the recent
news that the USO Genji managed to
secure themselves an investment of just
wait 46 million dollars oh yeah the orc
have been putting in the work on titles
like Call of Duty League of Legends and
a pub G and call the I'm investors that
included really awesome so excited Will
Smith Fresh Prince yeah the Fresh Prince
like kids you the guy well okay I mean
that's pretty cool I'll give it to you
to be honest with you it's gonna be
tough to be but I've got some over by HP
news and I think might just do it take
for instance these incredible new
releases that were announced in the last
24 hours
first up the omen X by H P 2 s is the
world's first dual screen gaming laptop
which means you can multitask between
your game and well anything else your
fancy to be honest with you the owner of
our HP 15 and omen by HP 17 laptops are
also both coming your way as well so
make sure you keep your eyes peeled for
those now if you're in the market for a
new monitor which we all are let's be
honest with you you want to check out
the omen X 25 and the omen X 2 F 25 F
excuse me display monitors which was
designed with the overwatch league and
will be used throughout the 2019 o WL
season lots of numbers also for usually
like three down 1 P 1 star we've still
got the omen challenging UK League of
Legends online tournaments in
partnership with Curry's PC world taking
place over the coming weekends secure
self victory there and you'll win
yourself some lovely prizes including an
omen obelisk desktop PC along with the
27-inch monitor or the new omen X by H P
2's dual screen laptop that we mentioned
earlier the sign up URL is on the screen
now and in the chat so what are you
waiting for
I'm ready to go and just sign up right
now because that would have nicely to my
set about home right for our final news
item we wanted to bring you something to
make you smile mark
especially for you eSports crowds have
been on their fire recently with an
outrageous chance and phenomenal support
and his two of the best crowds from the
recent I am Sydney and CW London events
[Applause]
[Applause]
well what an amazing final what an
amazing amazing way to NCW our London
please make some noise for both teams
who greatly credibly will make some
noise would you would look at that
absolute seams keep it up guys okay
that's the news done with so let's head
over to mark now to give us the lowdown
on the latest social media for me
eSports pays amazing stuff and yes
welcome to the control center as we call
it this is where we'll be bringing you
some of the snippets of action from
around the world from Twitter from every
single place that we can find to keep
you up to date with everything that's
coming your way so we're gonna start off
by looking at Twitter and we're gonna
start off by looking at didi Kay's
birthday this is coming in from the
blast Pro series that we saw very
recently in Madrid but this isn't the
most important part to be honest with
you because there's one man that we need
to highlight here I want to actually
keep your eye on this man here James
Bardo fantastic commentator not a great
dancer to be honest with you but
hopefully you know James will work on
that and I'm sure that DDK will have a
birthday he won't be forgetting for a
very very long time the next week that
we want to look at though is more
heartwarming moment even though the
birthdays are fantastic you know it's a
heartwarming moment from X teams to X
teammates we have TSM sending some love
towards double lifts here and it's
always good to see the community showing
love to each other and you can see it
here a heartwarming photo to go
alongside it as well great stuff there
from TSM now there's been a lot of hype
in another game that's very popular at
the moment that is of course fortnight
and this is about the current fortnight
Pat's that's just come out and you can
see CLG gaming here a little Asterix at
the end the pump shotgun voted one of
the most iconic weapons in the games
disappeared and be honest you could
probably see Co G's thoughts on that
particular process obviously there's
been a patch since there's been lots of
changes in fortnight and lots more I'm
sure to come ahead of the World Cup now
we of course want you guys to get in
touch as well with the with the show
today and you can do that by using the
hashtag I'm an eSports report we want to
have some questions coming in from you
for some of the guests that we have on
the show if you've got anything we want
you to had answered then send them in
and of course we'll do our best to get
those done as well now of course later
on as well we'll have a rocket League
challenge for you so a little bit of a
looking forward into the future here and
we want you to predict who's gonna win
that and how you
can do that is quite simply tweeting use
the hashtag team our core team Lottie
but of course we love you guys so we
want to have a competition for you as
well we've got so much to give you guys
and the competition is going to give
away some incredible prizes and the
price is going to be an obelisk
RTX 2070 desktop and an amazing gaming
chair and if you wondering how do I get
involved how do i how do I win this
fantastic prize well there's a URL in
the chat right now quite simply click on
that choose team Marc or choose team
Lottie and then you're in with the
chance of winner and that winner will be
chosen at random at the end of the show
now the control center I mean it's
obviously it's the hub of action right
now and we've still got heaps more to
come during the show as well we have
special guests coming your way we have
three members of origin joining us
fantastic stuff to have those guys on an
eSports legend in pull red eye Challinor
and pub G's favorite son Richard Sims on
top of that we have two features to
bring you as well as what to look
forward to in the coming months in
eSports amazing stuff we've got so much
to bring you lots I can see already down
there I think it's time for you to take
it away
I am indeed mark thank you very much and
you're very right as well because it's
time to welcome our first guest to the
area that I've dubbed
lottie's lounge that is right we're
gonna welcome three of the men behind
origins success in the LEC expec e Alf
re and Andre
[Music]
[Applause]
Andre looking very ready for business
I'm loving the attire right now and what
have we brought here the managerial role
I see just just a normal little casual
drop in there from my amazing supple
gentleman thank you so much for joining
us I'm gonna start with of course the
legacy behind your organization expected
obviously origin you guys have been
through an incredible journey already
talk to me about how you began what's
your history in your starting more like
a dream I always had since I started
playing by given on my first year on my
team he was more about bonding with the
team a lot being with the players and
something like this and I wanted I had
an idea that I wanted something on my
own
something for the future and improved
things that I wanted as a player on an
organization I'm one of these things
were for example being more reachable to
everyone in the team trying to have a
more family orientated idea of a team
and that's pretty much what I actually
what I wanted to achieve and when I felt
that I had done everything I had to do
with fnatic I just wanted to change and
do something else and look for new
challenges do you feel like that is
working for you is that the key to
success I think I think is working out I
have been a lot of abundance I had a
little success with Orion also a lot of
bad moments but I'm really happy at that
point I am now I would refresh and with
these guys doing good for the team again
now let's talk about right now let's
talk about 2019 how is the season going
so far what can we expect from you
moving forward as well I think I think
the season so far went went quite well
we finished second place on the spring
split which give us 70 points for four
outs our main goal that is going to
Worlds and now is just keep working keep
grinding making sure that that we can
achieve better better results which
would mean when the split but not only
we want to win the split but we want to
do it on with with some different
methods and and that's also what both
origin and refresh brings a lot to the
table so
also prove that those methods that we
are trying to implement can be a key to
success and and that that's ultimately
our our end goal for for the season and
not on this onebut but for the ones to
come as well
amazing stuff well let's just look about
the MSA right now I want to know what
you guys are thinking who do you who do
you have your money on well probably IG
it should be I mean they just smashed
throughout the entire group station and
yeah like there are some other good
teams like SKT and g2 but you mentioned
only the relevant in the group station
but that's no way they're winning
let's be honest and yeah maybe g2 can
cause an upset because it would be nice
if they won after they filled us but
realistically probably IG gonna mean
okay a quick question for you guys as
well as you know what your aspirations
moving forward as well and is there a
team but in particularly you have in
your sights that you want to take down
this season g2 GT really really good and
they smashed us two times in a row so we
nice to beat them again oh yeah beat
them I like that far you know you're out
for blood and it reminds me a little bit
of earlier on when when I had the
pleasure of performing one of our fan
favorites from season one of The Omen
eSports report and it was our headshot
challenge where we put our guests
through their paces on a csgo egg map to
see what their skills are like we asked
expec a and re to kick off the new
season of our challenge so let's take a
look at how it went down
we are back for another season of the
headshot challenge and I found my first
competitor x-pac a we've got quite the
challenge ahead of us right now sixty
Seconds to get as many headshots as
possible and I'll csgo aim at now it's
gonna be quite a difficult task but you
think you're ready I think I'm actually
quite really I haven't glued no well but
I'm pretty confident because I have been
able to warm up for a couple of minutes
absolutely why I've seen you warming up
on I'm quite impressed already so we'll
see exactly how you do let's get into it
okay it started you got this okay we're
warming up now here we go
we're already ten seconds through plenty
of time
there we go
I'll get hit as well yeah what do I get
for the target right we're halfway
through now 30 seconds left easy stuff
we've got this
he just doesn't want to go down there my
20 seconds left
oh that was good that was good here we
go hold on 10 seconds left 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
1 0
good what oh it's work the batch go back
not bad absolutely effective better from
my previous warm ups bother me hey you
had your game face on did really really
well but we got all fari up there how do
you think he's gonna do I think that's
for sure
well I found my second contender right
now Alf re we are pretty much ready to
go
pinning ok yeah I mean I'm feeling a
little bit pessimistic right now I'm not
exactly confident coz I've never played
this game before but hopefully I can be
expected if I do that then I'm happy I'm
not sure about that one sorry I believe
in you and I also believe in beginner's
luck so go and take your aim when you're
ready
we got it we got this actually boom here
we go time I started
yes elf re good stuff he doesn't want to
go no without a fight like the patients
I like the patients patients is good why
there's tons over this side we've got
this let's clear this out thirty seconds
were halfway through plenty of time to
go you are crushing this we've got
closer spawn there twenty seconds left
the patience is unbelievable from your
body wrinkle your patron thing
there we go ten seconds eight seven six
five four three two one oh there we go
there we go I'm impressed I'm really
impressed with that
that wasn't bad at all how'd you find it
I mean I did faster than I thought I
would but I still did pretty bad I think
yeah it went okay I suppose right we're
gonna have to find out the scores on the
leaderboard well there you have it
alfe re-watching that bat you crushed
that I'm impressed well that was a
half-hearted visum I'm not sure I
crushed it exactly but yeah it did okay
well I'll tell you what we actually have
the leaderboard behind us right now with
the magic of me there we go fantastic
Wow okay don't not sure I like to see
that at the top of the list
mark capture 26 points Wow okay and then
we go red by 26 points
third we got Andre and then we've got
soon 21 oh no Andre space Andre Smith ex
Hecate was third there we go they've
moved a little bit too fast my eyes
there and then I'll for you your drink
this how did you feel about that I
expected me to do badly but I didn't
expect do as badly as Andre so I'm
disappointed that I'm as bad as him
that's just yeah tragic honesty it may
be tragic but obviously you haven't
played yes before are you gonna be
practicing to get your skills up no not
really no not really thing I stick to
the Kardashians he's sticking to League
of Legends guys it's not for him but
it's time for another new addition to
season two of The Omen eSports Report
now where we ask our guests to give us
expert insight into one of their key
competitive moments mark was with expec
a and Andre earlier on to talk us
through it in this segment we call the
breakdown
all right there ladies and gentlemen
welcome along to a new feature for this
season and this is quite simply called
a breakdown this is where we have some
of the best minds in the business we've
got to the gentleman here from origin
and we're going to be breaking down a
couple of plays that you guys have made
recently starting off with this backdoor
play here yeah so this was a play that
we made against SK and on the second
half of the spring split and as you can
see here and if you play the clip we can
see that Jonas doesn't start the nation'
till the Blanc starts moving and that's
our plan if you could just stop the clip
here for a moment so we know that
LeBlanc and Yorick can easily divert an
exon on the on the on the Nexus turrets
so if they want to defend on us
finishing the game through bot they have
to send at least remembers which gives
us a free nation that's our first idea
now that's the reason why LeBlanc is
also moving bot is to force them away
from Nasher so that we can get the Nash
and then play out the game like that and
probably finish the game here but you
really see the TP or connector and when
we see the TP or nekked and we know that
their base is not defended and since
their base is not defender we have a
demolisher we just put those three guys
stopping the recalls and these guys can
just easily finish the game okay
obviously a lot of decisions to be made
in a very quick amount of time there so
something that obviously a sparring
player is gonna have to keep in mind
but speaking of players we've got expect
a next year and we knew this was gonna
happen you were waiting for this moment
because this is something that you've
done before yeah in SK back there I knew
this play was gonna come up and let me
tell you something that not everyone
knows about this play in general is that
of course we are maybe gonna lose the
game because we use lost a small fight
they're going to our base and I decided
to pretty much go to their base and try
to annoy them my initial intention was
not to finish the game it's pretty
irritating so they go back and they
don't know what to do you can play the
clip and you can see it more clearly
when I saw you and at this point I'm
just going to their base am I still
thinking should i TP show no TP what
should I do and I see the opportunity
and I just go for it hoping that they
will just stop going to our base when I
start hitting it and the first two hits
I see Olaf and I'll okay I stopped them
from pushing so I'm just gonna back out
and you can see my smallest step back
which is gonna be in one second here I
think yeah right here you step back a
bit but then I realize this is Olaf he
doesn't do anything he's just gonna run
around me so I start hitting the Nexus
walking around I'm thinking more and
more okay I'm gonna finish the game I'm
gonna finish the game until I finally
see choke and I'm one
hbn la okay well I died but at least I
defended the vase and I get the last hit
and I win the game one XP in a dream and
you can see the reaction there obviously
an incredible moment not only for the
game but for you personally in your
career absolutely amazing I was going to
kind of ask you very quickly you know
we've seen two very similar players
there from different times for aspiring
players what would be a good time to use
it or is it kind of a situational play
is more if I should not play because
they're back there is not something you
practice for Jesus
it's about being fast mind that I'm
being a bit of sneaky whenever you see
an opportunity to make a cool play go
for it and try it ok be brief is
basically what we're saying here from
the guys from origin fantastic stuff
gentlemen always good to get expert
insight into the gameplay that these
guys can bring you that's it for the
breakdown fantastic stuff it's back to
you on the floor thank you very much
mark amazing stuff that is so great to
have the insight there from Andre and
xpecting I've learned a thing or two but
if you've just joined us where have you
been
but don't worry we're just getting
started there is still absolutely loads
more to come read out on Sims will be
joining us for a chat our two big
features are on their way so don't go
anywhere now the first of our two
features is up next and it features me I
got the chance to take a trip down the
dota2 MDL DS in our major in Paris to
have a chat with some of the players
fans and talent see how they felt about
playing and watching eSports and the
happiest place on earth
[Music]
we are here at Disneyland Paris at the
four-day dota event the MDL Paris major
now this is one of the last chances our
teams are going to get to qualify for
the International and we've come here a
day early to go and catch up with them
and see how they're feeling before the
event how does it feel to be performing
one of the biggest events of the year
Paris it was quite a surprise I don't
think anybody expected us to be sharing
a hotel with Mickey Mouse it's gonna be
my first time truly having like the
support from the crowd I know it's gonna
happen and I'm really looking forward to
it
Disney owns everything now right yeah
and now they're now they're doing
eSports so happy to be a part tomorrow
is the big day
and while all the teams are off
practicing I'm gonna go and check out
some of the rides
well it managed to escape the rain and
I've got here early before all the
action is starting the stream is gonna
be going live very shortly and the stage
looks amazing as you probably hear is a
lot going on behind me getting set up
and ready to go and I'm gonna go around
and find some of the audience members to
see exactly how they're feeling about
the tournament
[Music]
earth in French in Paris Jota has never
really been a thing in France the French
communities I think really small was the
same in Mumbai in India when they are
very big in sport events and there was a
lot of very good reaction to it and I
sings the same in France and the fact
that we have seven French player big at
the top top of the world I think it's
really important to show it to the rest
of the world and in France in particular
how we spot can be it's just the
atmosphere to be able to be in the crowd
getting there
Cheers and it's cool because we can just
shake hands with the player who are
working here it's very cool hoji on so
why do you support it good just just my
team to be honest with you
they have my boy in my town my man I've
got a quick question for the pair of you
obviously the relationship is on the
line here but if one of your teams wins
the event you'll you'll be happy for
each other right
of course what an incredible couple of
days it has been at the MDL Disneyland
Paris major I cannot believe you got to
go to Disneyland I'm so jealous
like normally I'm not a jealous kind of
guy but that looked at main jobs not bad
at all that's very very it's very very
true and something else that I'm jealous
about of course is the chance that you
guys have to enter our competition that
we said earlier all you have to do is
click on the URL in the chat and choose
either team Marc or team Lottie on who
you think is going to be winning the
upcoming rocket League challenge indeed
our next guest is a man that knows
competitive dota very well he's been a
part of eSports for probably longer than
he cares to admit it's the one and only
red eye
[Applause]
that's weird by the way scary the stairs
that's terrifying
I do it when you come out in front of
hosts in front of people right when I'm
hosting that's no problem but during the
walk airliner that's horrible something
see me learn off some I am I've never
done it no I think I have making history
even now Paul your first when we play
games back in the day yeah which this we
didn't have these things you had to
bring your own stairs I mean we actually
actually miss each other by a short
fraction the MDL Susan um Paris major
amazing stuff there what did you make of
the event overall I mean another great
major sometimes I feel like we don't get
enough in dota 2 but then when you have
a major it comes along and you enjoy the
masses and exactly it's a big tournament
for us obviously in dota 2 and yeah
really interesting results all the way
through I think virtus Pro
underperformed and too few teams over
performed and but in the end we got the
kind of the top six that I thought we
would get actually it's quite
predictable which is really weird and
don't we don't normally get it as
predictable is that I mean I remember
walking in I managed to catch the first
game and it was it was a rainy Paris day
and there's a little bit raining for
some of the boys in the first game
because my goodness complexity that
match through you know it was just awful
when we have situations like that do you
expect that on the first day some of
those really sort of hard to take game
um
the group stages that donor events are a
bit weird they're all a bit weird
because teams don't they do care about
them but they don't care about them
because they all go through to the
bracket so it's more about are they
finding themselves do they feel like
they're in a good place they don't want
to give too many strategies away at that
point in the group stage because you can
get figured out really easily especially
when there's a meadow within a
tournament like that so it's very
difficult for some of the top teams to
perform in groups I feel
and I think that's why you see some
shock results sometimes I you've done a
lot of things in your time in eSports
because you know you've done it all
pretty much and I want to talk to you
about you know your little journey
through eSports because you know you've
been here for a while now you've kind of
done everything that needs to be done I
don't really know where to start but
talk about your little journey through
eSports 1863 when he sports was in black
and white I don't I don't know I've just
been incredibly lucky I posted a picture
the other day I came across a picture it
was from 20 years ago this years 20
years ago this year last weekend was
about to be showing well that's there
you go then I mean it's extraordinary to
me that it's 20 it's 20 years ago right
it's weebleandbob on the t-shirt and I I
don't know it just seems crazy to me
that it's 20 years ago that we first set
out as a team and show it to my fruit
friends by the way and we've been called
fruit there's my old team and yes we
will work different fruits
I was Kiwi before you even asking I'm
glad it went back to red eye but it's
crazy to think that 20 years ago that
five of us from all over the country
came together at a tournament won a
tournament together playing a video game
and it just it reminds me that this is
not antisocial actually it's quite the
opposite I have made incredible friends
all the way around the world from
different walks of life and different
backgrounds and religions and wealth and
countries and it's just amazing that I
am privileged to be able to do that and
that picture kind of reminded me of that
was the start of it really well I see
you as almost the godfather abuse oh god
please don't write the best kind of fun
yeah absolutely
I'm now of course we created this debate
across our industry and I think it's
quite passionate to you right now
because there's a pin to eat that's for
sure but eSports or eSports what what
are we thinking we could go on for hours
look I didn't this wasn't my fault
that's always tweeting about it i I
don't know how
every time the subject comes up you're
the one defending it I know or fighting
against people say you know what it's
like
inevitably I then I stopped posting
because it got frustrating so I just
made the image and then that way I just
give the image out that way a little bit
you know looking towards the future
obviously you know we know you're very
passionate about that you're very
passionate about about most things that
you do but where do you see eSports
going over the next five years because
we if you look back at the last five
years when it comes such a long way what
are your thoughts and what's about to
happen
I do you know it's probably the most
common question I get asked in a
business setting I do a lot of obviously
work with Co Reb where we're going to
speak to new clients and people that are
coming into eSports for the first time
and they often ask the square where is
it gonna be in five years ten years I
often tell them
anyone that can tell you where eSports
is gonna be five years from now is lying
because it's really it's almost
impossible seriously why could not have
predicted 15 years ago when I sat in my
bedroom doing shoutcast radio that we
would even be in stadiums and we've been
in stadiums now for seven years we've
been doing Stadium events nice was for
seven years filling them out all around
the world and I couldn't have predicted
that seven years ago I couldn't have
predicted it three years ago in many
ways so I think it's very difficult but
I think just bigger better stronger more
money more sports teams more non-endemic
sponsors more you know people coming in
and hopefully paying the players better
and improving the teams and putting more
money into each of the tournaments well
what do you think's the pinnacle for
eSports if you could if you could sort
of put your thought process into it and
you thought right this is this is the
limit this is the sky for eSports this
is where it's gonna be out what would
you say um I don't think it'll ever be
as big as football as a group but I
don't think it could be far off as a
collection of sports I think that's the
other thing people often look at you
sports and they think all right it's a
it's it's an entity right it's not there
was there's league of legends there's
dodo there's haloed as what have you and
each fan are very passionate about their
game right so it's harder to describe
that to non-endemic sponsors and people
that don't come from eSports because
they think of eSports as a sport so they
compared it to hockey or football NHL or
whatever actually they shouldn't they
should
comparing league of legends to NFL or
NHL or whatever and the same with
counter-strike and compare it to other
sports so I think if we can get to that
point where each game is as big as any
other sport out there maybe save
football I think we've done really well
thank you so much for joining us sir but
I think it's time for us to add another
guest to our so for now and to be honest
with you like I'm refusing to call it
loads round he's one of the leading
commentators within one of the hottest
eSports scenes right now of pav Bhajji
and also a man that I shared the
microphone with many times before
please welcome out ladies and gentleman
Richard Sims I think first and foremost
everybody needs to congratulate you on
becoming a dad it's weird it's strange
but in the best of ways possible
it's amazing and I hope he has a bright
future the same let's talk about pub G
because obviously you are you dispersed
yourself throughout the industry and
we've come across many titles but one
right now that's dominant for use pub G
talk to you about the rise of it what's
going on I mean playing it from day one
I will find it during the beat it is and
it was kind of in testing fairs and so
on and so forth and it's just come on
leaps and bounds the game is in a
complete different state to what it was
I mean the the word meme has been thrown
around eSports ready can be our eSports
be a thing and honestly I think pub G's
really changing the face of that and
proving that not only be are these
sports does work but you can mitigate
the RNG it's manageable update by update
the game changes face even now and it's
amazing States going to Sevilla it's
more than stable
we're getting a good amount of FPS I
mean a broadcast wise I still find it
really tough to watch it's much better
much better news I think it comes down
to and this is someone I was speaking to
another company about not too long back
it so far every tio has its own little
yeah change and how they need to
broadcast it and their own twisted and
their own changes but it's getting there
and now we've got a global rule set in
in the whole of the league's across the
world everyone's kind of playing on the
same foot I become it can it be fpp TPP
what certain should we have and it's
really streamlining now and it's it's
good to see ya I think it's gonna go
kind of that Rainbow six we're way it's
a really good each spot to Tier one and
jump off over another year this is pod G
caster by the way me I'm still was halo
let's talk about an event that you were
part of recently face it London cuz
obviously you know that was an event
that was a huge event for pop GE sport
you know what it was amazing it's the
first time and as for kind of sojanet
things are changing it's the first time
I've ever heard a crowd going wild for
pub G and okay it's it's it's very and
we have noticed this there's a lot of
Chinese fans the Chinese this is insane
and the way they get behind their teams
it's it's mesmerized fantastic to watch
and you can hear them we have two
Chinese teams there and the cheering for
them was just fantastic and there is a
there's a famous clip online where one
guy gets a grenade from the ground onto
all four players and just and that
that's what's the common believer and
you could see with the observers they
went from first person to third person
over the top watch the grenade then you
had an observer literally waiting on top
of all players just waiting to receive
that shot and it's things like that
they're going to make you better and the
tools and pugsy keeps giving us more
tools to be able to cast it and really
show it off because I think for me and
Lauren we've discussed it a few times
it's a story how did team a drop at
location here and how did they die or
gets and survived at location B and the
obstacles that kind of handsy yeah just
all the obstacles I and it's it's an
unwritten story and I think that's the
it's been difficult for me transition
him from play-by-play regular just
what's on screen to trying to go for a
more color stroke hybrid but it's good
and it's fun in that event was just
amazing we saw another Eastern team win
another team yet again proving that the
West has still got to step up okay we
saw EU and na 2nd and 3rd but still not
get into number one in a global scale
just yet
absolutely well Sims something near and
dear to my heart of course is halo and
little halo corner we got going on here
as well but let's just talk about the
future right now because there's been
some big change on the horizon in comes
a halo about the Master Chief collection
coming to PC and I think that it's you
know it's not just us as fans I mean
what are your thoughts on that I mean
for me I think and I've always said this
people say you know it's it's amazing to
be a caster it's like I think you're
what we'll all say this one
it's just halo in it's right it's at the
heart and no matter all these players
that have been a big each spot or at or
a big eSports level they always remember
halo 2 halo 3 the golden era the golden
game and I think in every single where
possible halo moving to PC there's no
bad points about it every single point
is is positive and it's only going to do
wonders for the franchise already on
Steam I think it's the most whitelisted
the biggest wishlist item to come out on
MCC already on Steam and I think it's
just going to blow up and it's only
going to do wonders for the franchise
and then rolling off the back of that it
gives a good tester for where world life
when infinite finally comes out and when
we see that and where that goes and kind
of what direction or kmcc is gonna be at
set games and we know but again for the
franchise as a whole
giving the PCs option not moving to PC
but giving them the option to play it
it's only a big positive but I used to
play more in console by myself not never
like tournament-style or anything just I
didn't even have internet when I played
it it's everyone's favorite game I find
everyone's done it in some way or some
other and played it at some point in the
lives the reason the born expose yeah
it's I didn't want to I didn't wanna I'm
not a console player at all I hate the
controllers but I
but because that's one forward - I mean
I'm just excited to the fact that you
know what plays are we gonna see come
play halo you know months maybe a VC
community do you think I think that's
the most important thing yes we'll see
some of and again we don't know what's
going to happen with a full eSports
player base is such an which weird and
you know Microsoft's gonna go but it's
gonna be amazing and being able to see
all these new players opening up to the
world I think we'll see a couple come
out yeah fantastic we're always great to
speak to you rich and out we'll be
hearing more from you later but it's
time for feature number two coming your
way now and this time we're asking the
question just how do a sports
organization stay relevant in today's
world we've got to be Wester are some of
the biggest names around to offer their
point of view so let's take a look
[Music]
there's no denying eSports is huge and
at the center of it all organisations
competing at the highest level with
investment at an all-time high
the competition has moved outside the
game the question is how do these teams
stay relevant in the next billion-dollar
industry
[Music]
in 2018 eSports broadcasts were watched
by nearly 400 million viewers worldwide
spectators are tuning in to watch their
favorite sites face off in their
favorite games but in recent years the
way these teams around has changed my
name is Karen Holmes Darby I'm the
managing director and co-founder XL
eSports my name is Mike riffle I'm the
owner and CEO of indie gaming
incorporated I'm Richard Lewis
I've worked primarily as a journalist so
what's happened to eSports teams back
then everything was very team centric
now what we see is at the top CEO CEO
CTO CFO this is a huge cultural shift
that now eSports organizations are being
run as businesses with teams becoming
more business focused has in-game
success become less important for us
winning will never be less important we
were considered one of the most elite
eSports organizations in the world for
many years I think we still are winning
was really the catalyst for all that at
the end of the day is much easier to
build a brand around winning but winning
is not enough anymore what's happened is
success is only as important as to the
business in today's world it's all about
building that media side and building
that brand even if you don't have a
winning team at least engaging with the
fans is a platform for us to have a
business as long as the fan engagement
is existing for us then we have
something that advertisers and sponsors
and media companies want but above all
that teams are striving for one thing an
identity identity is a very hard thing
to come by an eSport and you have to
differentiate yourself you have to have
that USP ours being the sort of go to
British eSports team and having our base
here in the UK is really important for
us
the key word everyone always talks about
is authenticity
that is the key and make sure you are
authentic in that in the claims you make
in the place you make in general I think
it's very important for every eSports
organization to find their own identity
and find something that makes them
unique
I think our unique ability is producing
live events and shows on a marketing we
just proved that this past weekend where
we had 5,000 tickets sold for two
straight days events like this are
changing what's possible for eSports
teams to do some massively competitive
industry both in game and outs of games
so as soon as you see an eSports team
doing something great and there's gonna
be a lot of teams wanting to replicate
that or do it better do it slightly
differently this out of game
competitiveness could mean it's a bright
future for organizations I think we're
in for a lot of exciting times both in
terms of the successes and failures that
are gonna happen I'm now looking five 10
years in the future and not at the
short-term immediate goals winning the
next tournament doesn't mean we can fund
ourselves for the next three months to
you know get through the year we're
building a business model and a strategy
that lasts for a lifetime it is still
possible to create a team that will
stand the test of time it is definitely
something that takes a lot of work and
thought because you have to find this
healthy balance between your fan base
your investors and your core beliefs and
if you manage to do that then you have
something amazing it's a perfect time
for us to introduce another new segment
for season number two and it is called
best of three now here we have three of
our guests we give three of our guests
the chance to speak about their mind on
a topic and that video has given us the
perfect subject and that is quite simply
is winning trophies enough these ways
these days I should say these ways these
days gentlemen it's over to you start
with you Richard what your thoughts on
this I think and I'm not at that level
where I've been a player as such to be
able to you know speak from from that
perspective but certainly I think
there's a yes and a no side to it yes
for the players and the fans
I feel like winning will always be the
main thing they want to be lifting that
trough for the fan base wants to see
them lift up of the head the players
will give them the confidence moving
forward to be able to achieve mahram you
know that's what you want working
forward
we see them now that these guys don't do
this for free just cause it's gaming
doesn't mean that it's you know it's not
a job we all have homes families to
provide for and everything else and
there has to be some kind of income from
that you sponsorship steals the the
prize money it's a job that has to be
income from that and it's not just
enough to be able to support them in the
ecosystem that's to be income at the end
of the day as simple as that but I
certainly think trophies are a good
starting point for any organization if
you want to get your name on the map you
have to be bringing it bringing it home
at the end of the day you have to have
something to prove I'm dying to know
your plan I think this is a it's a
tricky subject I kind of agree with what
Richard Lewis said in there in the video
it's a business now and we have to be
mindful of that that said if we just go
businesslike then we miss out on all the
cool stuff that we used to do the
passion I remember that photo that we
showed earlier 20 years ago I went to Al
and we didn't care about how much money
was offer I think was 200 quid for that
weekend we didn't care we went along
because of the camera Audrey because of
the passion because we wanted to win a
trophy so I think it's really important
that yeah we treat them like a business
is and and we do the right marketing and
what have you I think I always think of
the Dallas Cowboys in this situation
doing the only sports and energy thing
but hear me out here it's 23 years since
they won a Super Bowl but they're still
the most valuable by finance franchise
in the whole of the NFL so it doesn't
matter that they haven't won a trophy
this to the success there's still a
massively successful company so I think
we need to have that kind of mentality
in eSports for the top organizations as
well but contact me this guy doesn't
want to win another trophy yeah I mean
winning I think is not necessary but it
obviously helps a lot and I think is the
right mentality to have when you're a
player or an organization you just try
to win things you should not try to not
win and become the best by not winning
and on the eSport sites of course but
you want to try to build more than just
winning out at least how I always saw it
as a player and as a teen owner is try
to connect with the fans as much as you
can try to do things with them and if
you if you win what you're doing that
then you're gonna get big for sure but I
think you should never focus stop
thinking about winning but don't make it
you don't make it don't let it blind you
that will be like if I don't win I'm
depressed if I don't win my career
sober because that's not everything
valid points there yeah great I think
it's good see sort of a balance of
argument as well I mean you know I
wanted to ask you expected as well cuz
I'll close it you're on the other side
of things at the moment that connection
with the fans you're saying how
important that is when you're not
winning tournament that becomes even
more important to have those guys pick
you back up again yeah I mean for me was
always super important to even go out
take pictures with the fans when I lost
sometimes you can because you take a big
hit and it's impossible but I always try
to force myself to be like remind me I'm
here thanks to them you know and I yeah
I couldn't believe I still can't that
sometimes I want to take a picture with
me so I try to put there for and if
someone want to take a picture if I have
to queue up for a couple of hours
do it because in the end thanks to them
I think we're all here doing so I knew
sessions after losing big matches tough
thing to do is it is a tough thing to do
and amazing opinions from all three of
you guys but your opinions aren't the
only ones that matter we want to hear
from you guys at home as well because
you're here with us on the only sports
report on we want to know what you have
to say about this debate so all you got
to do is open your Twitter hashtag oh
man a sports report and let us know what
you are thinking but a light note now
moving on we're mark our marker mention
that our competition earlier where you
have the chance to win a prize by either
backing team Lahti great choice or if
you made the mistake of backing team
mark in our rocket League challenge so
without further ado let's find out who
kicked off the new season install with
the win and find out which of you guys
we're making the right decision you
can't down so here we are on the main
stage it is about to go down in the
rocket League challenge now of course
it's going to be team Lottie taking on
team mark and my teammate I need to
introduce of course is someone that
we've got a litte bit history so we're
hoping that connote that can help us out
in game
Richard Sims how're you feeling how much
rocket League experience have you got
I'm feeling good however including this
lobby time experience rise it's this
lobby time and this is a face of instant
regret but anyway let's move across to
our team light
how you feeling about things obviously
got a red light alongside I'm paying
great I've got an absolute legends
recruited on my feelings today to
Daniel's we're putting it down to my
quickies cars and football if I'm not
good at this game I suck it's rocket
League Rumble remember we got abilities
we should probably think of using those
rates I love a wrench you love the spa I
know evidence on the wall I'm nervous I
gotta hit this where's the ball I didn't
hit it I like it I like it I like it a
lot I can't even see the ball okay
what's a goal even though it's kind of
like you play chance I'm magnetized it
to me apparently entirely sure what's
going on this doesn't seem like rocket
[Applause]
viewers of Homer to be interested right
now are those who voted for team mark or
team la a team are your choice you got
to I don't know
it's nice turned into a tornado so the
balls frozen the poor Liz may have only
one of us did Ariel yes able to go a lot
some of these goals I see you know
you're not kind of no nominate all right
doesn't matter we were just easily won
back earlier on you began a come on
range robotics we got it okay
I keep forgetting to hit the ball Oh
real issue
[Applause]
[Music]
no no don't I feel so good to win wow
wow this time on main stage you know it
feels really good being able to say well
done to everybody who voted a team
lotty because you obviously chose right
red are you have been a fantastic
fantastic teammates thank you so much
your strategy and tactics were spawned
Lahti love it you can come again you can
come again well let's find out exactly
who has won the competition applause
plays I mean like I mean I said I
wouldn't throw you on the bus rich but
next time I'm picking you that you're
gonna come play with the only bus I see
right now is the winning person in red I
have front-row we ruled that game we had
such a good start
yeah now one up and then Paul decided
basically didn't you should have been
dealing with it I don't do football
never go for Liverpool anyway what was
the disappoint in time for me we'll move
on and we'll give you some good news
because I have the fantastic privilege
of announcing our competition winner
from earlier today obviously some
fantastic prizes on board and the winner
is Patti fairly so congratulations to
you we'll be in touch and obviously
[Applause]
thank you very much today we're bringing
you our new segment of called the mother
forehead here's all the things we think
you need to know about the coming weeks
we brought you up to speed on the msi
earlier in the show versatile
[Music]
the action picks back up on May 17 in
the taipei but before we get down to
business with the grand final May 19th
with one team will walk away with the
trophy and $400,000 semi final one
starts at 11 a.m. on May 17th so make
sure to chew in then following on for
that expect a we've obviously got some
exciting things happening there $400,000
fancy a piece of that pie I mean I think
everything's gonna be fighting through
that there is for sure but we're moving
on now after that incredible event we've
got Dreamhack Dallas it's on next
unmissable one on the calendar with
three days of competition from May 31st
to June 2nd across the multiple titles
and genres highlights include the csgo
Dreamhack masters and rocket League
Dreamhack pro circuit I'll be tuning in
and I recommend that you do the same
this next one's a little closer to home
when faced it's ECS season 7 finale
taking place at the SS II arena in
Wembley on the 8th and 9th of June
tickets are still available for what
should be a spectacular showcase our top
tier csgo so grab some friends and hold
on down to support your favorite teams
and upcoming next we've got dota
that's right red eye now with the
epicenter major set to kick off in
Russia on the 22nd of June I know you've
been to Russia before but first you'll
be hosting the berm u movement yes yes
n1 berming is coming up for us at the
end of May which has pretty much all the
top teams in the world going so we're
looking forward to that one just before
we get to epicenter but yeah looking
forward to the final major of the season
as well we've got some big teams in
Russia as well they're ready to go toe
to toe you won't want to miss it and if
you're a fan of Valve's popular MOBA
then
lastly for those of you who fancy
yourself at the next Lewis Hamilton yes
you read Iona yes there's still a chance
yet honestly qualification for the f1
eSport series is ongoing with a deadline
to register a time for the third
qualifying event closing on May 19th now
to make your marks there you could find
yourself in a race off event on the 27th
the 29th of May and if you make it there
then you're within touching distance of
joining a professional racing team now I
can breathe to get all of that it just
keeps showing us how much action we've
got to come doesn't any much we have so
much but I've had an absolute blast yeah
episode of the season and gentlemen
thank you so much for joining us thank
you guys an absolute pleasure thank you
one of your insights that mark that's
pretty much unfortunately that is all we
have for tonight's show but a massive
thank you for everyone who's watched
today thank you for tuning in to the
first episode of the new season here at
the omen eSports report we'll be back on
June 26th and guess what we're gonna do
it all over again we can't wait thank
you so so much
good night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]